foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Monday in Clearwater Florida Jim Cantore
The Weather Channel in Southwest Florida
and I saw a tweet from Jim before 7 A.M
that said the hurricane now 155 miles
per hour trying its best to become a cat
5 which I think is 157 158 miles per
hour and then Jim goes on to say one of
the strongest hurricanes in Southwest
Florida history and Jim joins us now Jim
where are you
uh well I'm backpacking some of my stuff
because I have a feeling I'm going to be
spending the night in my car because
we're gonna get some storm surge here in
Punta Gorda Florida which is where I am
Dan and
so we're gonna go we got a parking
garage we'll get up a couple of levels
in that and and let this thing come in
and do its thing man
how bad do you expect it to be
very very bad
um you know if you go and you Google the
Shaffer Simpson scale and you look at
the different categories when you're up
there on a high-end four or low five it
doesn't matter if it gets to five now
it's still you know unless it goes way
into the five uh but the point is it's
still the same type of catastrophic
damage homes roofs trees and power lines
mangled just about everywhere and of
course the element with this that we're
worried about is storm surge I mean 12
to 18 feet damn which puts some of this
town that I'm in or a lot of it anyway
underwater explain that storm surged to
me
so storm surge is the rise of water
component on the east side of a storm uh
you know there's all this wind that
comes over the water and you have such a
low pressure you have a compensating
water rise for that so all of that is
following the Hurricane's landfall point
all right and wherever that is
especially if it's to my West which it's
forecast to be the right side of that
eye which is where I am is maximizing
the storm surge so this morning again
you saw pictures up in Tampa bay where
the wind was actually blowing the water
out here in Charlotte Harbor we had
offshore winds and that blew the water
out but the water's gonna come back in
and it's going to come back in with
waves on top of it and it's going to
continue to rise into that 12 to 18 foot
level so that's what happens when you
have a hurricane there's almost a little
slope of water that adjoins the eye wall
right into the coastline and of course
depending on the approach is it 90
degrees to the coast
or is it more angular you maximize your
storm surge the more you know
perpendicular you are to the coast who's
getting hit the hardest
or what you expect I mean Lee Charlotte
Collier counties up to Sarasota County
and the fact that this thing is so
doggone strong again it's not going to
wind down quick uh it's going to come in
and you're going to even have damage
into Orlando I remember after Charlie
which this isn't going to move that fast
but it's so much bigger it's going to
kind of make up for not having that
speed uh there were there were like
literally mulch cities
because there was so much debris
everywhere that they had to mulch all up
so I mean it was incredible I'll never
forget that image driving by in Orlando
after after Charlie uh back in 2004.
what's the worst one you've been
involved in
I mean they're all bad you know they're
all you know
any any any major hurricane there's a
lot of damage but sometimes you know
like let's just say Harvey after Harvey
came in as a cap four in the central
Texas coast then it became a 65-inch
flood in the Houston Metro area so it's
like what what what's bad you know what
was bad all of it uh you know anything
that floods certainly anything that
causes a massive loss of life and and
property uh is bad so Dan just to I
don't know if you can see this tell me
if you guys could see this yeah you can
see it yeah all right so the top part is
what we call the reflectivity
the bottom part is the radar estimating
the wind speed
so that's the eye wall you see the 122
miles an hour yes in that eye wall yeah
that's what's coming in toward Captiva
right now as we speak and that's what's
heading up my way so I'm watching this
and last time we had uh you know
Hurricane Charlie back in 2004 that the
waves in the wind were so bad they
actually made a cut across the Barrier
Island they call it the Captiva cut I
expect several Cuts in several parts of
the Barrier Island to really take a
catastrophic hit
how do you maintain composure in
something like this it's your job but
there's got to be part of you that
nervous
yeah I'm always nervous for my crew I'm
always nervous for People In Harm's Way
I mean there's
but I'm on Mission I mean how do you ask
a guy who's on the front lines how do
you maintain composure it's your mission
it's your job
so you know you have that responsibility
to to do that I mean it's not perfect
sometimes you get tired sometimes you
see someone suffering and you're
Torn to Pieces because of it and that's
really hard frankly to maintain that
composure because you want to suffer
right along with them this lady
downstairs her name was Barbara she uh
she just gave me a big hug before I came
up here and uh
I mean that was that was nice I needed
that
so what do you do the rest of the day
I'm going back out like I said I came
back here to our hotel because given the
storm surge forecast here in Punta Gorda
I don't know if we're gonna be able to
get back here tonight when we finish
doing our broadcast so we're probably
sleeping in the car in a parking garage
uh so I just want to get some things
some food to bring back you know some
drinks
um Gatorade water things like that just
just to go back and and ride it out
there and hopefully we'll be able to
walk through back to our hotel tomorrow
you know but I don't anticipate anybody
having power
let me tell you that you ever been in a
gym where you thought you know what I'm
I'm I'm in trouble here
I mean never like oh I'm in trouble here
because you can always go up you always
have to leave yourself an escape route
to go up I mean the cars and all the
other crap you can replace uh in Katrina
we lost everything uh on the parking lot
and
the good news is we were there at the
Armed Forces Retirement Home so we could
help out the Navy CB unit that was based
there a lot of young guys you know
strong young and and but basically when
that water started coming in that
building we got a chance to help them
you know bring those vets our vets up up
to the second floor out of Harm's Way
but you know the problem is is the water
came in the food is down there all the
medicine is down there
um and of course everyone's having
breakfast when Katrina came into
Gulfport Mississippi so
that that was one of those things where
it's just like you you can react and
freak out
or you can pull yourself together change
your mission now you're a part of the
mission with these guys and and you try
and help as many people as you can and
you know I'm proud to say nobody died in
that
nobody died in that Armed Forces
Retirement Home and these are heroes
um you should see that thing now Dan you
should see that place it's it's a
fortress it's up on still it's 30 feet
off the ground
so uh if you ask me if I'd ride out
another cat for her five hurricane there
you're damn right I would absolutely
what would you say to the people who
could be listening to this show or in
that area that uh you think is right in
the middle I hope they realize hey how
fast the water is going to come up when
the winds come around from the south
because it's weird this morning because
it's actually going down I mean there
are boats literally sitting
in Harbors that are tied up they're
sitting on the ground kind of tilting
over like this but when the water comes
back in you know now you're talking
about it's got no place to go but um and
and
then if it breaks if some of the wind
breaks the uh the boats loose they're
just at the mercy of the wind and you
kind of wind up with this big pile of
boats you know in the in the corner of
the marina so that change in wind
direction brings in the water it also
brings in the eye wall which uh is
making its way toward Captiva as we
speak and there's still so much
lightning in that eye wall which is
usually a sign of a very well
established uh hurricane that even could
intensify for them
great to talk to you be safe as always
thank you brother appreciate it Jim
Cantore meteorologist uh Weather Channel
and
you know there's part of you that you
have to want to do that
because that's that's what your job is
and it's important to do it
and uh to be able to go in and be able
to report uh
letting people know this is serious